this is an interview with the authors of
the paper transformer memory as a
differentiable search index i have done
a comprehensive review of this paper
yesterday i've released it just before
this video so be sure to check that out
the authors today have actually seen my
review and will dive right into the
matter during this interview you will
not only learn much more about the paper
itself but also the research project
itself what went well what didn't and
what the authors think of the future of
the field this is super duper
interesting it's an absolute pleasure to
interview all of these people and that's
possible because of you so continue to
let me know in the comments what you
think how i can make this content better
thank you to everyone who shares out
these videos to everyone who's part of
our discord community to all the
supporters on patreon and so on and
without further ado let's get into the
video
hello everyone today i'm here with itae
and don metzler who are authors of the
paper transformer memory as a
differentiable search index which i find
really cool really inspiring uh very
creative and very happy that you are
here welcome to the channel
yeah thanks for having us thanks for
having us
um this paper is a bit special right
because it
it takes a little bit of thinking
outside the box i think to overcome or
to arrive at the conclusion hey let's
just store the entire data set into
transformer weights or
you can frame it in whatever way you
want but it is
not an obvious idea how did you get the
idea that you want to try something like
this
uh
yeah so maybe i'll just share a little
bit from my point of view and then don
ken can go next about his thoughts uh
so i think for from my side i'm really
interested of like you know
understanding like this is more of like
understanding the properties of
transformers and you know how many
documents can transformers encode in the
parameters and you know like and then
obviously like retrieval is a good way
to test whether a model is able to like
generalize like what and digest what he
has like you know encoded in memory so i
think from my point of view it's more
more of like uh you know trying to see
what
transformers are capable of and and
pushing the limits of memorization uh
and then yeah so i think that's uh from
my point of view uh i'm one of the more
in the the the reasons why uh we thought
of this at the start uh yeah maybe don
can share some
some thoughts as well yeah yeah so i'm
taking just a you know sort of a step
back um this paper is somewhat tied to
this paper that we published sometime
last year called rethinking search
um which laid out kind of our vision for
you know how we can bring the latest and
greatest and machine learning natural
language understanding to bear on sort
of information retrieval problems
um there's been a lot of you know
interest in in the space recently and so
one of the things that we talked about
in that paper
um was this i mean essentially this idea
um you know how to essentially
take these large language models that
exist which understand relationships
between sequences of tokens
and imbue them with an understanding of
uh documents right because usually these
sequences of tokens come from documents
right um but i've never seen anyone
explicitly model that
um and so from my point of view you know
i'm sort of more as a kind of ir
researcher and you know it's great that
you know ye sort of has more of the
machine learning nlp background um you
know we decided to come together and say
like hey what can we actually do here
um to to study this you know is this a
crazy idea is this even possible um and
so one of the things that you know we'd
hope to do is actually
see if we can build like this idea of
you know not even like an evolution of
language models that are more of like
corpus type of models right where you
have documents
now and in these types of models
potentially not we didn't do it
necessarily here but in the future right
you can unders have models that actually
understand relationships between
documents
um and you know we we established this
okay how can you um you know model
relationships between token sequences of
tokens and documents but i think you can
take this sort of a step further and um
yeah so so that's kind of like the
broader framing and how we came up with
this then also i mean obviously a super
cool problem from like the machine
learning natural language understanding
side things as well
i think it's been long suspected said
however you want to call it that
transformers especially the large
language models they essentially
regurgitate their training examples and
kind of interpolate their training
examples was this in your mind as you
went about that research or how does
that connect to people saying well all
gpt-3 does is essentially you know kind
of reproduce a bunch of its training
data sets
um
it is like a good question like uh but i
guess like beyond memorization we we are
also kind of trying to test for like
whether the model can make use of the
memory because like if it is like you
know you give a model prompt and it
generates like from the prompt it's like
you know associative memory and stuff
but like
like you know maybe understanding of
documents is like maybe slightly beyond
that and we want to like just prop this
ability of the models because you know
if you can do zero shot retrieval here
it kind of you know implies that the
model has you know understands like like
reasons a little bit with what he has
memorized so i guess from an ml point of
view is at least some kind of benchmark
like type of
task to kind of probe for for this type
of ability in the model um yeah so i
think yeah
now i had i had a bunch of questions
maybe technical questions about the
model so i suggest we kind of clarify
these first before we go into more
the broad or the the meanings behind the
things you have this uh contrastive
objective here that you present in the
dual encoders and you have the fully
differentiable differentiable search
index have you
tried or there are these things called
cross encoders right where
i input a query and a document and i try
to predict some sort of a score of how
they go together these usually work
a lot better than the dual encoders
themselves what is the reason that you
chose to not compare to any cross
encoder type setups here
uh yeah sure that's a great question i
can take that uh so the reason why we
don't compare with cross encoders uh is
because generally cross encoders are
pretty expensive uh because you you
cannot like cache the documents in
advance and and you have like you always
have to uh you know uh compute for every
query that comes in you have to always
compute with all the documents so so uh
that's that's there's some like you know
latency and some
compute cost restrictions for cross
encoder so like within the scope of dsi
because dsi is basically uh you know
generating dog id so like we we kind of
uh put that in the same ballpark as
you know a similar
uh you know compute course as uh you
know like instead of doing a uh
like you kind of uh instead of that you
you kind of um
decode one document so we consider that
computer compute costs like to be uh
more fair than you know having to pass
through a pipeline of like and not like
usually there's another re-ranker that
does this cross-attention uh
stuff and then that that definitely
improves the performance and i don't
think that at this point of time like we
will beat across across attention
encoder uh uh but but you know
mainly cross encoders are just expensive
so so that's why we we consider it like
our scope for for this um
that makes sense uh you hear you
very elegantly you output just a list of
document ids i was wondering have you
ever tried to actually produce the
document itself that you're searching
for instead of the document id because i
was wondering because the model needs to
learn this association between the input
and the
document id and it kind of needs to
remember what text is in that document
right there's no other way for it to
really learn to associate text with
document ids and i was wondering is it a
harder or an easier task for the model
to directly output the text of the
document
what do you think
i think there's
a lot of challenges with decoding the
text i mean you can obviously uh you
know constrain your beam so it should
only generate stuff that is like
within a certain like stored memory and
stuff and then you that's definitely
possible or at least maybe the title of
documents uh but then i think that would
like uh we have not tried that in this
work and then you know i think this is
definitely interesting and it's a good
point that uh that you brought out but i
think that
uh at least within the scope of this we
wanted to keep the the compute low and
and you know like we already we have
already enumerated a lot of
possibilities in representing the dot
ids and then that will probably be a
different class of of uh uh a style of
dot id representation like they're using
like uh natural language that that that
can be that that can be like follow-up
work uh but the reason why is because
the reason why we mainly don't explore
that now is because like there's a lot
of like
additional challenges that that we need
to think about and and so so we will
consider that like slightly out of scope
for now but but that's definitely like a
great suggestion and and we think that
is uh is also
potential to be quite potentially quite
viable as well
the the only other thing i quickly add
here you know going back to you also
your question about the crossing
encoders um you know i mean
these models typically have limited uh
you know ability to
essentially model context length right
so you're limited usually to
passages or parts of documents right by
sort of modeling the document id sort of
as itself you you sort of open up the
ability to model larger more complex
documents that you wouldn't be able to
do sort of if you uh you know we're
treating everything as sequences of
tokens which again sort of the standard
um from the ir perspective it's been
from again my very biased opinion very
unsatisfying to move away from sort of
document retrieval to more passage
retrieval that has happened recently and
a lot of that has just been because the
models have not been able to handle
you know these uh longer longer
sequences uh like they did before so uh
this this takes us a little bit back to
to that
um and
uh you know obviously if you have longer
documents and whatnot it'd be even more
challenging to uh to potentially decode
that entire document
though isn't that it isn't it a bit
because if i think of information
retrieval in the let's say the olden
days what i actually retrieved was
keywords right and then i simply looked
up which documents the keywords belonged
to and i had some heuristics of how i
combined uh for an entire document all
the keywords that were inside of it
couldn't this also the move to passages
be viewed as an expansion rather than a
reduction in the scope of what i'm
looking at do you see what i what i mean
yeah yeah for
for sure um i in yeah i mean obviously
there's always a way to aggregate from
the passage level to the document level
and you know i mean this is the a very
standard trick that people have done i
mean people even did that back in the
you know olden days when you just had
you know sort of keyword-based indexes
as as well so um
for sure but um you know then you also
do have
considerations of of efficiency right if
you're going to then go and have to
score dozens of passages per document
that suddenly explodes the cost versus
just scoring sort of at the at the
document so there's definitely
trade-offs
here
is this what this introduces is a level
of
redirection or a level of indirection in
what the model needs to learn so we no
longer map sentences with the same
meanings to each other for example we
now have to learn this in direction
almost like addressing a document by a
variable name even with your
semantically meaningful identifiers
still i believe a large part i as a
model i need to remember just this
identifier
means something it stands for a
particular document do you see this
applicable
in
maybe a broader context you already
allude in your paper that this could be
part of a differentiable architecture
where do you see
these types of indirection based models
going
oh yeah that's a great question actually
i was waiting to this talk about this
because it's something i'm pretty
excited about so like i mean so the dog
id is like using the dog ids is like you
know you as you mentioned in some
interaction you store the the
information in some um you know some
address and then later on you can just
use that address as a you know in
replace of like a long document and
stuff so i think one possible like
avenue here is like you know like you
can imagine like uh you know like from
tunings uh you know like this few shots
in context learning might require like
you know like uh you might need to like
stuff 10 prompts uh 10 examples in in in
this large language model so like if
this um you know memory addressing type
like architectures that allows you to
compress stuff to dock ids and then you
know you can use that as for like prompt
tuning or you can use that for like
retrieval uh augmentation so i i think
that that that there might be more uh
use cases that can be explored like
beyond retrieval so this is more like a
fundamental i think that you you already
um you know um
you you've got it really very accurate
where um you know it's a class of models
that uses this memory uh you know kind
of addressing stuff that they have that
may have more uh wider applications so
yeah we are also quite excited about
that so yeah and we think that we it can
be like on top of my head is mainly like
maybe like
prom tuning or like retrieval automatic
augmented models that that could benefit
from this uh but yeah as well now we
don't we don't know that for sure but
yeah this is just a that's a guess yeah
in your paper you describe
the performance of your models and the
trend seems to be if i recall this
correctly at least if we go to the
results section real quick that
the
larger models do perform better however
the larger the data set gets the less
the improvements of let's say the dsi
compared to the dual encoders are if i
understood this correctly and in your
data sets you're still in the realm of
300 000 documents on the for an ir
problem that is not really a large scale
problem uh do you
think that in the future
people might be able to expand these
models to
also become better on larger
document or collection instances or do
you think that the application of these
types of things might be as you say much
more in as a differentiable component in
something maybe in an info maybe in a
reinforcement learning agent or
something like this like how do you how
do you deal with the fact that as you
seem to scale the document collection
size the benefits get weaker and weaker
uh yeah so that's that's a good question
so uh
so bit we kind of think that uh you know
like it gets harder and harder like as
you increase more documents i think
that's also because uh you know the
model has to like you know memorize like
you know i'll link link documents to
like much more identifiers uh so
to to be honest like when
the memorizing uh you know the interplay
between memorizing and retrieval is
actually quite um you know um
it's quite tough for the model to to to
to learn and then you know as you can
see that you need like excel xxl model
to almost do this uh you know do well on
these tasks but i think that uh you know
to cope with larger documents there are
multiple ways like one of them
potentially is like
you know like sparse models mixture of
experts where you know you can just like
increase the parameter size
significantly without um you know
increasing the compute so so we think
that those are also promising to you
know scale these models up uh to like
maybe a multiple of a few million dogs
at least this is like estimate we don't
have the results yet to show this but um
this is what we think uh uh right now
and yeah it's true that it gets harder
and harder like like uh eventually so um
we're not sure where the limit is yet
and and we are also excited to find out
like where's the
like where does this end and where's the
limit of this yeah
do you have an idea of how these things
scale like if i have double the amount
of documents do i need double the amount
of parameters or do i need an order of
magnitude more parameters like does this
does it
is it related linearly exponentially do
you have any idea of of how this scales
um
off the top of my head i don't really
like i'm unable to like put a number on
it like like right now uh it's mainly
like you know
the intuition is is uh
and it actually actually also like a lot
depends on like there's one part which
is like the memorizing capability
because like i believe that you know uh
uh beyond this paper we have actually
tried like
brute force memorizing like a couple
million documents the model does
memorize but then there's another like
you need to factorize other part of like
how well the model is able to make use
of this information so uh like it
depends on like the data set depends on
like many factors uh so it's very hard
to say but at least on on on nq like we
we don't have currently we don't have
beyond like 300k uh
documents but like going from 100k to
to uh to 320k documents is like it was
really like uh
uh like it wasn't really like exactly uh
trivial so so so we expect that um
like going to like a one million dollars
like in the retrieval context will be
like i i okay if i had to put a number
on it probably like you have to probably
may need to go to like
32b
or 32 billion parameters or something
like that yeah if i had to like give a
like a guess and an estimate
yeah and obviously this is the you know
sort of standard feedback we get when
you know people take a look at the paper
right you know lots of questions about
the experiments other data sets scaling
it up you know uh you know i don't want
to give too much weight obviously we're
aware of this we're working on this we
hope to be able to have better answers
to all of these questions
sometime soon and also to you know
demonstrate that you know this works
more than just on you know on and do on
some larger data sets um and hopefully
have much better you know sort of
empirical basis for uh you know
understanding sort of limitations and
scalability of these approaches
i have to ask just for
it's a i mean it's a detailed question
but this nq 100k data set it seems to be
just out of place a little bit like it
seems like the numbers they're just
kind of off uh there is it looks really
good with the 10k data set and the 320k
data set uh you can see you know things
either get better or worse maybe as
you'd expect but then the 100k data set
it just like for example the bm25 is all
of a sudden a lot better right then
either on the 10k dataset and the 320k
dataset and likewise in a bunch of the
other numbers it's just sort of out of
place do you have an idea of what's
going on with the kind of the data set
as such
yeah yeah sure uh so
like i think if you look at the numbers
right now like the one of the points
that stand out the most is the
the the the bucket of the atomic dog ids
right so uh the the second stuff the so
if you even you look at nq 320k like you
see a
6.9 there like randomly right so so the
the the fact is that for atomic dot ids
like there were a lot of
training like instability issues that uh
that we had to overcome so like there's
a lot of variance and a lot of
trainability issues and and and we we
tried our best to to overcome those uh
and then like so sometimes you you get a
base model to doing better than uh it is
more of like optimization and like the
interplay between um like uh you know
like the retriever and memorization
sometimes i mean i think if you know
like coming from my experience of
running like many of these like like
like logical reasoning or memorizing
tasks sometimes the model gets it in the
end and then sometimes it just doesn't
get it at the end by the end of the
training so like i think that's that's
generally like uh especially for atomic
dog ids because we initialize um you
know like the the the softmax layer is
like initialized from scratch and we use
the pre-trained models and and also
depending on the warm-up and everything
like so so it was already a challenge to
optimize uh for the atomic door ideas
that's why you see generally like even
on all three uh sets right that's like a
very
um
i think that the rest of them scales
pretty like more
nicely than the domino ideas but that is
actually a big challenge that that we
had um
i'm not sure if we actually like as
explicitly point out this instability
issue too much uh in the paper but but i
i i think i remember like mentioning
somewhere but yeah but at least uh you
know the middle the middle bucket is
it's really hard to train uh the the
second
you mention it yes
yeah the other thing to mention i i mean
if you look at the bm25 number i mean
that's not trained in any way it also
obviously demonstrates very different
performance there i mean the other thing
is just i mean there's variance when you
sub-sample the documents right so if you
go from 320 000 to a hundred thousand
you're sub sampling right maybe that was
just a very lucky good set of documents
that were somehow was much more amenable
and much more relevant in in some you
know way so um i mean if you do this
with like any sort of i think standard
ir
system right you just start sub sampling
documents in different ways you're going
to get very different performance i mean
probably the best thing would have been
to sub-sample you know like five or six
times get some sort of error bars there
to get a sense of what the variance is
so i suspect that you know probably it's
a mix of the instability plus the just
the fact that maybe this is a lucky or
you know sort of different sample of
documents in the 320k in the 10k i
actually have a i have an answer about
the there's there's one point which it's
a bit implicit it's not like i it's
mentioned but it's like it's not very
obvious but like so for nq 10k and nq
100k these are sub sample sets from
enqueue right and then mq320k uses the
official validation set right so
there's like
10k and 100k
is sub sub sampled and then like i'm not
exactly sure how the validation set was
constructed in enqueue but
like so 10k and 100k like uses a
like a similar way of sampling the the
is just random but like and when you go
to 320k like uh it's actually using the
official validation set so i don't know
maybe it's like maybe a bit cleaner or
like there's some difference in in the
way this uh this uh
uh so so 10k 100k and 202k came from the
official variation so there might be
some differences in
in the way we sample and how the other
people sample so uh yeah
so i i believe that you men you
mentioned the training instabilities
also at points throughout and that might
also explain a little bit as well why
different methods are good at different
tasks right you have there's quite a bit
of variance in which methods are better
here or there
quite a bit of variance in the numbers
itself although what i see is
very
thoroughly the case is that the larger
models tend to do better in general
whenever a model wins here with whatever
way it tends to be the larger models
that outperform the smaller models
within the same buckets do you think
that is
a property
of
the larger models being pre-trained
better because larger models also
exhibit better language modeling
behavior right and given that these are
pre-trained uh i guess t5 style
checkpoints
that that might be an improvement
because as far as i understand it your
retrieval performance also in a part
depends on
the models being pre-trained to actually
understand language especially the zero
shot ones
or do you think that
is mainly a a the main contributor is
that with more parameters i can memorize
more documents so could you comment on
that and maybe also a little bit on what
do you think intuitively is going on
inside of these models that they are
even able to retrieve those ids
so i think the pre-training definitely
does contribute like uh i wouldn't be
able to say like how many put the number
on like how many percent it contributes
to that uh but i i definitely think that
like one way to tell is like probably to
just rerun all the experiments with like
each like randomly you should initialize
uh
uh you know t5 style models right uh i
think at a very early stage um i mean
it's not in the paper but we did run
some early experiments with like no
pre-trained models and
these models actually
like it's way harder to to learn without
the pre-training and this is you know
it's a common finding across uh you know
not only in this context but you know in
broader nlp and machine learning in
general so we think that the
pre-training does a lot of like uh heavy
lifting and also the size uh you know
like with a larger model you also bend a
bit more from like you know like it's
composition of two different things
helping each other so because you you
know you are pre-trained and then you
you also you know larger and then you
benefit more from pre-training when you
are
uh
for for this t5 uh xxl models so i i
think that also probably contributes to
like the the zero shot and and and and
and stuff like that so uh yeah just to
answer the correct the question uh um
explicitly i i think that the
pre-training does contribute a lot to to
do this yeah yeah i think the other
thing we don't have a good understanding
of is you know after we fine tune uh you
know on on these the dsi tasks you know
what
sort of the model what knowledge the
model retains or does not retain right
um you know what was the nature of the
model at that point um as others have
sort of asked this question and i think
it's a great great question um
i i do suspect that some of the the
knowledge that you know sort of uh
obviously you pick up during
pre-trainings is helping as you
suggested but um but there may be other
pre-training tasks that are even more
amenable to sort of dsi than
you know uh sort of the standard t5
pre-training
did you have you attempted at
introspecting these models in some way
to kind of see whether you can
find the documents whatever it means in
inside of these weights like
you know
i i imagine since i can query these
models and they give me a doc id that i
i need to be able to go and look inside
the weights or something and and find
traces of these documents or something
like is there something you can say
about the inner workings or or is there
something one can see in the attention
maps or in the weights
i i have a very disappointing answer
because i wish i knew like where to look
in the model as well uh but the
unfortunate thing is that i don't don't
know where this is
safe in the model is it in the you know
the decoder layers but i i think
intuitively it seems like you know
because the decoder learns to like like
output dog ids i think the decoder does
quite a lot of like heavy lifting uh in
the model but like which weight is in
and you know like you know there's also
like you know like the the fit four
layers like key value memories and stuff
and then you can you know like somehow
probe that uh i think this is
interesting for a lot but unfortunately
we don't
know where where is safe now in the
model uh yeah
is there um
what do you think if people want to get
started with this what do you think is
like the smallest scale thing that would
still give meaningful
insights into the technique because a
certain scale is necessary if i
understand this correctly right
but what would be kind of the minimal
setup for anyone to get into this type
of research like differentiable indexing
and things like this
um
yeah that's a very good question
actually um
so at what point where this starts
getting meaningful right which scale
does it get meaningful i i guess like
this is just my personal opinion
obviously like this my sense of things
but uh i i think starting at around like
uh like excel like 3b uh it's probably
like a
reasonable scale to start because uh
okay actually i i don't really know why
3b but like this is just for my
experience running this experiments
because like uh like
3b and and and 11b
um
has slightly different training dynamics
compared to bass and large so uh it's
very hard to like quantify like you know
like characterize this like uh it's very
latent within me uh but but i think like
3b somewhere around 3b is like you know
like
medium scale models like uh
but like like small and bass probably
will not be that meaningful but like i
guess like starting from 3b would be
pretty nice yeah
so that is not it's not exactly small
right i can't i can't really run this on
my on my 1080 at home but it's still i
guess
maybe maybe accessible to more people
than just the biggest companies
um
here you have you have a pretty
interesting thing in your
hierarchical document ids and i
understand this is not the end-all
be-all this is like an attempt at
forging
meaningful document ids and you make
very interesting requirements here you
have two requirements that
they retain some semantics which the
clustering i would say gives you right
it gives you a little bit of semantic
thing but then also you want to reduce
the search space which is with each
decoding step which is a property of
auto regressive decoding right the first
decoding step only needs to care about
the big picture the next one the smaller
and the smaller do you have an idea how
much these two things
play together or which one is kind of
the important one because one could also
i think in the review i raised the issue
you could reverse
this in this document id which would
give you the same
meaningful document uh identifier but
without this property of autoregressive
decoding do you have an insight of which
of the two properties might be the more
important one here and which one is or
are they interacting with each other
so we have not like really like
factorized both both of them
uh
i i interactively i think that the
like
segmenting the search space is
more beneficial but i think they help
each other uh i think this like it's
possible to also like come out ways of
like emulating this uh but i think we
did not like uh
try try those yet yeah
um if you if you look maybe a bit more
high level
no wait i have one more question yeah
this l right here because you have this
very interesting graph that shows this
thing right here which document
representations make the most sense and
direct indexing i i also find it
interesting that in your paper you try
out a lot of things and then at the end
it seems like often the simpler things
work better um which is which is a neat
finding i guess a an encouraging finding
for a lot of people
although
i was surprised to see that
if you index fewer tokens of the
documents it tends to perform better
what's because that shouldn't be right
uh what's the problem here what's the
problem that prevents us from indexing
longer sequences of the documents
so i i get okay so this is this like uh
my my thoughts on this is that like
going up to one to eight and above uh
makes
the the training harder uh like we also
observed this in memorization like you
know looking at the training accuracy or
memorization so i i think by
and there's going to be like quite like
some
like examples or we don't know how many
examples but like there's gonna be like
uh some examples that can be solved
easily by the first 32 tokens or 64
tokens so i think that the model like
okay this is just a guess i i'm not like
really 100 sure about this but it's like
the model prioritizes like
like uh
getting the one it knows like like
correctly rather than trying to like fit
256 tokens and then like not being able
to solve like like anything right like
even the easy one so so i i think this
is this might be might be what's
happening uh and then like this 32 i
will not like over index on like this 64
or 32 because it's probably going to be
like very data set uh
dependent and also the inverted index
like i saw on your you know review that
that you were surprised that
inverted index didn't work right but
this might be like an artifact of like
this data set like and and uh you know
like it is maybe the simpler purchase
book here but like when we when we go
when we scale up when we go to some
something like uh harder or more
documents or just the the structure of
the dataset is different then perhaps
the inverted index like what would help
uh so so i think that there's there's a
lot here that that you know we are just
showing like a a slice of the the data
points but like but like uh i want to
over over index or like oh dsi only
works when the document length is like
short or something but like i i think
this is the data set dependent and and
uh
and and
for sure i believe that for other dss
you you need longer sequence line um
yeah
if you look ahead a little bit and you
came into this uh you told me at least
that um
you
you just wanted to know certain things
like you had some questions is this even
possible and so on my question is is
there an end goal here if you look into
the future maybe two three five years or
so you you develop this a little bit
hardware gets better and so on what's
the
what's the outlook what's the
the north star that this could lead to
um
yeah so i'm going to share a bit and i
think dawn surely has thoughts about
this as well so i i i will leave some
for him uh
so i i think like one of the north star
here is like because like you know like
retrieval is generally like slightly
decoupled away from like other nlp does
like you know people are unifying models
they are going for t5 six everything is
six to six right but like when it comes
to retrieval uh you always like have
this separate infrastructure of uh
of uh you know like dual encoders and
then you have to compute like you know
ranking metrics and then the whole
infrastructure is always very different
from like say like like machine
translation or text generation stuff so
like i think this like uh at least for
me like one one aspect of like uh is to
be able to like conveniently do
retrieval uh in a way that like you
don't have it you don't need to have a
separate infrastructure you can just
co-train your retriever get all the
metrics you need get the competitive
performance to like do encoders uh while
you know like still being able to do
machine translation
at the same time so
i became maybe maybe machine shop
station may not be the best example but
maybe you want like you know some nlu
some some uh some question answering
model like you know end to end or you
know like or synthesizing uh like from
the dog ids you you can you know like
generate dog ids together with text and
then like you know like maybe
substantiating the text with with uh
with with uh you talk ids like you know
like learning to site and stuff like
that so so i think these are like
like the the you know like uh visions
the vision that that you know i'm pretty
excited about so um
yeah maybe don can can chime in yeah i
mean um you're going back to what i
mentioned at the sort of at the start
right um this is part of sort of this
this exploration of you know what's
possible
um and you know if you play this forward
we have no idea right what's going to
happen um i mean one potential outcome
is that you know
it turns out that this is is a great way
of actually modeling um a lot of the
things that the sort of ir community
again in the past is sort of modeled um
in terms of documents and terms and you
know sort of all all of all of this um
and that you know kind of uh this type
of approach
um you know could could
you know um be you know the sort of a
way of unifying
sort of retrieval and
scoring right because you mentioned
across encoders right today usually as
as you mentioned earlier right you have
this sort of cascaded approach where you
do retrieval first and then you do
scoring next this does everything
together jointly right and that kind of
simplifies things um
and it would be nice i think in the
future to be able to have a way of doing
that all sort of end to end in a
heightened differentiable you know sort
of way um the the other thing that i
mean is obvious here is that there's a
lot of attention and interest recently
with you know retrieval augmented sort
of everything um the idea being fewer
parameters and more reliance on sort of
external uh you know
memory or storage in some way right this
this is kind of diametrically opposed to
that um i think there's pros and cons of
both
of the approaches and it'll be very
interesting i think to see as we
continue to explore both directions sort
of
what are the benefits of
of each of these things and how maybe
the two of them can come together as he
was suggesting you know maybe dsi could
be a sort of inner loop on a retrieval
augmented uh approach
in the future
and if you look ahead maybe a bit more
short term what are the hardest problems
that are still outstanding to make the
next steps of progression here
there's actually a lot
[Laughter]
it's good right as a researcher yeah
there's a lot of like like nice things
that we want to solve and there's still
a lot of things that keep me up at night
so uh i
i think there are a couple of like
pressing ones like how do you update
documents uh how do you uh you know and
then solving the trainability issue and
then just solving the scale to do like
you know i'm hoping that you know like
going to sparse models like something
like switch transformer you can just
handle like 20 30 million dogs like off
the bed uh but so i mean i'm like i
think scaling is is is is a you know
like a more short term to mid term thing
that that we want to solve uh so
updating scaling and also like the
interplay between like retrieval and
understanding a little bit more about
this zero shot uh behavior and then also
understanding where he's in the model as
you mentioned like understanding this
behavior of these models i think these
are like in uh immediate like next steps
that that i think like this
in order to you know take this uh idea
further like i think
these things need to be uh like to some
extent like soft or at least like
like figured out somehow yeah
yeah and
obviously i mean some of the questions
you brought up here are you know things
that are actively being thought about
and explored um you know one of the
things that
you know we were just talking about was
you know indexing the first like 32
tokens right i i yeah so so just
understanding you know properties of the
model across more data sets um and kind
of like what are the best practices
here i think are also like very
immediate term things that uh that we'll
need to do to just get a basic
understanding of this beyond kind of
this initial kind of proof of concept if
you will that this crazy idea is even
you know kind of feasible
um is there any anything else that maybe
we haven't touched on yet that you would
like people to take away from the paper
uh that they shouldn't go without
knowing
that's a good question
yeah yeah no i can't think of anything
right now yeah but yeah yeah
okay is uh can people
even if the models are large could could
people get into this like is is the code
somewhere available or
are you planning to make it
okay so this is like subject to approval
but uh yeah we we do have plans to make
the code available sometime in
uh q2 uh of this year uh but buddy this
is also like subject to approval we have
not gotten the approval yet as of now
but uh this is our
plan uh due to release in q2 yeah
the fight with the lawyers
excellent
we have a history of you know of
releasing uh of open sourcing you know
many of the you know you've reviewed
several of our papers in the past right
i mean we do have a history of you know
uh being able to release the code it's
just a matter of you know sort of
checking uh various boxes and we're
committed to this we've already had
folks reaching out you know trying to
replicate this and we want to make it
easy for everyone so that they can you
know sort of get going with this and uh
yeah i think it's a really interesting
area hopefully this will stimulate some
additional fun research
yeah i was i was in in google for a
while i know i know it can be a hassle
to to open source anything
um and the amount of approvals you need
to get so props that you even like want
to go through with it it's pretty cool
all right so don and yi thank you very
much for being here this was very
enlightening and i hope people
had fun
and i hope to see you again soon
thanks for inviting me yeah
it's great yeah
[Music]
you